thank you
so today I'm gonna try something that
I've never done before
we're gonna talk about how to fail in
particular I want to talk about things
that in the field of interpretability
that I saw over the years that we should
do or shouldn't do and this the name of
this workshop is emerging challenges in
deep learning
I guess interoperability is one of the
emerging challenges in learning
I'm gonna go one level deeper like
inception and talk about emerging
challenges in that one or the field of
emerging challenges and of course as
always all these are on my opinion of my
own not representing Google in any way
so what am I talking about how to fail
so this all started when I read an
article about inverted thinking a couple
of months ago
what is the inverted thinking it's
trying to think how to fail in order to
succeed and I'll give you an example I
find this really powerful let's say
you're in a conversation it's tense
conversation high stake conversation in
your either professional setting or
personal setting and you have all these
emotions and things that you won't talk
say say to the other person in that case
take a step back and think about how can
I be a terrible person what should I say
so that makes me look terrible and try
to envision what they would look like
what they would feel to other people to
you and try not to do that for some
people it comes naturally this is this
is true yes people may not use this
method is because there are thousands
way you failed and there are just you
might need want to prevent from your
failing though my point is that there's
the rare ways to succeed prop probably
people try to think how they can succeed
in the Asia so the this more efficient
to think about the methods that you can
success let's talk about that more about
that at the end of talk if you'd still
agree with philosophical yes
King in the area of motor checking this
is what is being done because they're
trying to create culture examples that
show that the motor fails and then fix
this battery is really based on trying
to find failures all day all day
that's amazing yeah so it actually goes
back to Carl Jacobi perhaps in long
times where he always emphasized
importing the problem and he said that
you can hard math problems can be
clarified by reexpress in that problem
in on a morning I think and people in
old-time stoic philosophers also
practice this method of premeditation of
Evil's so they got me thinking how I can
apply this in my research over the years
I saw some really encouraging trend line
of research and interpretability but I
also saw a lot of concerning patterns
like things that we probably shouldn't
be doing if we want to make progress
things that we should be doing if our
only goal is to publish papers but not
if you actually want to make progress
and I can easily think in five to ten
years maybe there will be another
silence workshop and we'll be circling
around and drinking beer and someone
asked so this field of interpretability
you worked on what progress did you make
well what what what is doing the last
ten years and I try to think in what we
should we should do so that the answer
to that question is I don't know you
don't do anything last ten years
so this talk is based on this opinion
article that I wrote a couple of months
ago just like any other subfield in
machine learning interpretability is
going through some hype these are papers
number of papers that are published in
interpretability and Google Scholar just
interpretability I think Julie is a
slight networked numbers are small
compared to maybe mainstream deep
learning but I think if this is exciting
but we want to make sure that we are
actually making progress so why am I
keep talking about actually making
progress because we've been here before
in 1980s when expert systems is a hot
thing
there's the subfield code ye-es
explainable expert systems so you've
already recognize this is a problem that
we want to solve communicating complex
information to humans and lots of papers
were published probably some people do
PhD on this topic and I do think that we
gained a lot of insights from this line
of work but it's probably also safe to
say that we didn't quite solve the
problem so we want to make sure that we
are going in the right direction this
time
so this talk is about my own reflections
of this field 11 items of how to fail I
think of this as opportunities for
failure for success and I realized that
these observations are subject to my own
subjectivity my opinions so to make this
more concrete I reviewed all the papers
that were published in last year I say
melon Europe's and I'll tell you some
aggregated statistics and some examples
of how whether these papers fall into
any of the categories of failure and I
also realized that I have a unique
opportunity today to have theoretically
minded people in the audience so I'm
going to try to propose how Theory can
help interpretability
these problems are yet to be
well-defined but if you're interested
and these each item that I'm going to
talk about is a talk of its own so I
while I hope that this inspires you to
think about a lot of other ideas that
you have to try to avoid the trailing
the talk please only ask clarification
questions during the talk I'll leave
time for discussion later
all right so this talk is not about
pointing fingers I will be pointing
fingers and myself things that I've done
wrong things that I wrote in my papers
that I wish I didn't but I will try to
block out the paper so I'm going to talk
about the names of course I'm not gonna
show you the author names and I will
show you some figures which you may
recognize which paper it came from so I
just want you to let you know that I did
like a lot of these papers just because
you have this picture here doesn't mean
that I don't think that this paper
deserves and I've also hope that this is
not just sound like me venting working
in this field if you sense the sign of
venting that means that I care and of
course this is the whole point of this
talk is because I want the field to
succeed so it's not at all a pessimistic
view of the field and I hope that this
new way of thinking would help us
viewing these issues and problems from a
different angle
so here's our agenda many many different
opinion about unities to fail first
failing in motivation setting
expectations how out offering what
interpretability method can do in to
hopefully making an interpreter bility
method i'll fail in evaluating one and
how to fail in giving that explanation
to people and having them interpret that
explanation and how to fail finally so
let's jump right in how to fail in
motivation how to fail number one we
need interpretability to increase user
trust and julius alluded this
excellently earlier but interpretability
and trust or a completely different
problem you may get trust as a byproduct
but as we will become more clear I think
what interpretability message should do
is err on more helping people distrust
the model and yet 17% of papers claim
some connection between interpretability
interest and I was one of the first ones
to fail this is the abstract of my PhD
dissertation where I wrote these
symptoms also must be transparent to
earn experts trust and be adopted in
their workflow and this is the only time
that Trust occurs in my entire thesis
but I regret this deeply and I have to
live with this because I can't edit my
dissertation and what I lacked back then
is what it seems to be naive jump from
transparency to trust was completely
wrong in fact if your goal is to just
gain trust your best bet is to look at
psychology literature there's
disturbingly many literature on how to
manipulate evil and how do mean you
build about
for for political reasons
and the reason that I think why
interpretability message our air on more
distrusting people is this thing called
automation bias what is automation bias
it is a pattern that humans have in over
trusting machines when they shouldn't
the first empirical evidence was
observed in 1993 when human engineers
were in the job of detecting when engine
fails when the engine status was on
automation they can only detect half
less than half of the failure cases then
when engine status was immanuel another
case would be a particular interest of
people who plan to fly home after this
workshop is this study in 1992 when they
put pilots in a simulation and they
presented a scenario where one of your
engine is failing you have to shut off
one of the engine and they told the
pilots to shut off the wrong one and 75%
of the time they showed up the room one
now I think that's alarming but I think
it's what's more alarming is the base
rate base rate is 25% now note that you
know it's 1992 it's different
but I think it's interesting showing
there's a huge amount of literature on
human factors on automation bias
Joshua coral recently wrote a beautiful
paper that says because of these many
biases just requiring explanation is not
sufficient
and this paper I also talked about in my
previous talk I think Julius alluded to
this beautiful work came a couple months
ago that showed that the deep learning
model was not looking at this medical
image where the information should be
coming from instead it was looking at
what machine took this picture the model
of the machine and other things that
shouldn't matter they figured out this
out via oblation study given all this I
really think that interpretability
method should people consider
distrusting the model and as a kind of a
sidetrack when you're doing user studies
I think it's very important to add this
bogus option like a random explanation
just to make sure that we're not just
fooling ourselves that you didn't gain
you shouldn't gain trust in this case
you shouldn't accomplish the task in
this case because otherwise we don't
know what explanation is helping
how to feel number two we need to
understand every single bit of the model
we may not be able to there are human
superhuman performance Network where
this may not simply be possible
I view interpretability problem as like
a translation problem this is a hard one
but we're trying to translate the
machine language to human language and
for those of you speak two languages or
or three or four you may know that there
are words that you can translate you
cannot quite translate one to one but
you can kind of try to describe what it
means to get the meaning across and
that's still helpful
15% of the paper did not mention any of
these uncertainties that these are not
not everything about what model is doing
and here's our first theory question
interesting theory question that I think
you'll be interesting to try to quantify
how much coverage we have is this
interpretation that that has on the
model so if you're familiar with the
software engineering there's a unit test
and we there's lots of different way to
define how much this test covers the
entire code base I think there's a
another work that tries to the similar
things with a learning model a couple
years ago or months ago I think you'll
be interesting to try to come up with a
definition of how we can define the
coverage or interpretability method how
much he covers the model
what is coverage I tell you I was
thinking more like if the model is
superhuman performance then perhaps we
can only understand 80% of the model so
I can explain for 20% we can explain
that kind what did that mean something
does that mean something I think it'll
be useful to for example say you have
similar similar accuracy one is do you
have two models one has better coverage
dollars maybe in some cases you want to
choose
[ __ ] fail three yes respect to Wyatt
right like the oftentimes like we knew
when you said the models not using the
features who wanted to use what you're
saying is you're speaking to an
anticipated scenario where the
distribution on which you evaluate the
model is not the one on which it was
trained I mean there's a lot of
difficult questions you could report a
coverage number that really becomes
meaningless in that context I think
there's that there's a lot of difficult
questions to think about and discussed
about oh it's interesting how to feel
number three every model must be
interpretive no you don't need
interpretive of machine learning all the
time in fact I think some things that we
think we need interpretability now maybe
come in a situation where we don't need
it anymore for example perhaps you
realize that's your best option or maybe
you have enough empirical evidence that
it works then you accepted the mistakes
that it might make then maybe you don't
need it
in fact there are a lot of things and
technologies that we use currently that
are not interpretive or other cases you
may only care about performance
you don't need an ability it's a lot
next up how to fail in making a method
how to before we first have to define a
universal mathematical definition over
interpretability that works for every
single case for all tasks for all users
but before that we have to hold off
everything I just don't think this is
possible I would like to do it I don't
think it's possible because if this were
possible then psychology cognitive
science asking what would make people
happy or sad would have been solved by
now what would make people satisfy and
help them in any case for anybody I just
don't think this is possible however it
is very important speed of being clear
of what your definition is in your paper
what do you mean by interpreted in your
paper mathematically or either
human-in-the-loop evaluation because
only then your paper is useful if I
don't know what your definition of inter
probability is how am I supposed to know
a little reader whether your paper is
relevant to my application or not
now unfortunately 40% of papers did not
clearly define what they mean by
Interpol and these papers has
interpretability or interpretable in
their title I think that's a little bit
one too many here's my favorite example
this works that in this work we are
interested in on a formal motion of
interpretability
I'm not sure what that means do we mean
a fog '''l away all the interpretability
and left with own interpretability or
does it mean maximal entanglement I'm
not sure I fail to find this exact
definition of this in this paper
an interesting theory question here is
let's think about like the simplest
setting where you have a 2d data points
let's even assume that you have Gaussian
distribution something like nice and
simple like this and let's decide on the
task and the user like you're helping
people to debug for people developers in
Google in that case can we think about
what the optimal explanation would be
what would make them maximally perhaps
under try and constrain what would help
them maximally devote them all and while
this would be a made-up scenario it will
be limited I think it might help us to
think forward where we're going water
lack what we are lacking or different
other than tall columns
how to field number five the performance
and interpretability trade-off is
inevitable this is not true they could
be mutually reinforced eighty percent
almost 80 percent of papers show that
there is no trade-off between the two
here's some papers that show that GNN
has some more accuracy that it was
theirs there's another paper that showed
that there interpretable method can eat
uninterpretable method and here's
Cynthia's paper again on how to opinion
piece where she said that this trade-off
is not necessarily true it doesn't mean
that it's always false necessarily true
in fact here are some papers that showed
the trade-off
here's x-axis on accuracy y-axis on some
definition of interoperability and they
show that the trade-off exists so it's
obvious I mean there's no poetry
discussion if you have short explanation
you have only few possible explanations
and therefore your approximation power
is smaller No sure there are things that
fall under this small approximation
power but the trade-off between a
express ability of the model and how
complex the model is is clear
mathematical statements I see I think
that's a good point I think the
difference between what we're talking
about is definition of what is what it
is interpretive or in any definition is
a short description
you're comparing items that do not share
anything in common besides the fact that
they both like the word interpretable
I mean you report 80% there's there's
nothing if he's not it's happy to
comment these are interesting
discussions I think I want to defer this
to later not sure what you're asking but
I get what you were saying let's let's
talk about this because I mean and then
you didn't actually characterize the
trade-off like
what quantity is accuracy and the other
quantity is a different thing on every
single
yeah I think we have to talk about the
paper itself to actually get into the
detail but let's let's discuss harder so
I mean interesting theory question
though is that under different
definitions of interpretability some are
simple and some are may be non trivial
can we determine what case the trade-off
happens and when in what case perhaps
the answer is that there is always going
to be the straight of under on a
definition that will be useful to know
then we want to kind of figure out what
these papers were discovering all right
these are definitely inspiring
interesting questions I love it let's
discuss this over to lunch alright and
this is I think one of the most
controversial thing and and I think it
stems from someone someone point it out
do finding things differently and
perhaps we're-we're-we're the ring after
all so let's keep going how to fail
number six how I present the
explanations doesn't matter the shortcut
the fastest way of failing of any
interpretability method is having a poor
interface or workflow design of how
users would see the information
and if you discuss with nobody with HCI
expertise or cognitive scientists you're
guaranteed to fail and if you talk to
practitioners this is pretty commonly a
great form and oddly so I think HCI
expertise is one of the most
underappreciated field while that's why
it's it's important like when is the
last time you used on app that was just
interfaced was just so bad that you
should be able to do this in two clicks
but instead you did like ten clicks and
I should also emphasize that HCI is not
just about interface it's about
designing the workflow studying what
users really need and look at the entire
spectrum of usage from learning the tool
using the tool debugging the tool and
the whole thing there's a lot of science
in it here's some examples for a good
laugh if you have time in the weekends
and you want some good laugh I highly
recommend going to this link data is
ugly in the reddit as a thread really
good I had hard time picking these two
because there's so many good ones so
here's a visualization that are designed
with well-intentioned that quite didn't
work out so here we are looking at a bar
graph tech job girls in the 10 100
cities and there's only the height of
the bar matters that represents how big
the population tech top was but the map
is bird eye view you can't quite see the
height of the graph cars would have been
a good addition but it didn't cross
there's another example these are
ranking of law schools over the years
and I think this means like how much
fluctuates the ranking was over the
years so yeah it makes sense but then
after 18 it's like I'm not sure what
this is going where this is going
so next up how to fail in evaluating the
method name Julius this talk was a
perfect setup for this powerful number
seven since there is no good way to
evaluate interpretability methods I can
only show you qualitative results
now imagine a paper a classifier paper
that you're selling a classifier and I
never gave you the test accuracy and I
just picked a couple of data examples
that looks challenging to classify and I
said look I can classify these data
points but at least you would have some
number for tastic your theory I hope yes
I think that's a problem the qualitative
cherry-picking good looking examples how
do I know that it generalized how do I
know that what worked for you and this
one beautiful example would work for my
case forty percent of the paper I think
that's too many we're only showing
qualitative examples as the results and
here's some of my favorite ones this one
is picking out this is a test data point
and picking out some positive examples
that positively contributed to tradition
of this negatively contribute to this
example they're comparing with some
other baseline and while the author says
that provides their their method
provides clear positive and negative
examples I have hard time reading this
I'm not sure if I'm supposed to read the
color of the animal we're similar and
that's because and that's why I could
have been confused because this animal
is different from that elephant any more
I'm not so sure here's another example
this is a question answering paper where
the boxes are your explanation so for
example if the question was what is are
there any trees in this picture then the
boxes are around the trees
it says here's another paper here's
another picture with toilet and a table
I'm not sure why there's a table in the
toilet
in the bathroom but in this example is
this the prison toilet there's some
boxes on the table and there's some
boxes on the toilet I'm not sure what to
read from that is that good at it why
not smaller box why not box that
contains both of them I don't know
there are other papers that defined what
good explanation is mathematically in
this paper the alignment which is the
definition of reversibility is a measure
of how similar the input image are to
explanation their definition of a good
explanation is how similar they are to
input image so what's the problem with
this is you can think about attribute
explanation method where I just give you
input image right back then it's the
best explanation method under this
definition where was this public either
I say ml or in Europe's and another
paper this defines that we observe that
this method generates accurate
interpretation that better comply with
clinicians intuitions and here under
this definition good explanation is
whatever your users like whatever that
make sense to humans while your users
might be happy your goal is to interpret
the model not the users so what model
might be doing is might be completely
different under this definition I can
also think about a bogus explanation
method where I just give you back what
you want to hear an echo what exper says
and under this definition that'll be the
best interpreter ability
and what is wrong with this I think
Julius is talk talk about the cupboard
is pretty well when we have a salience
email with fine network and when we
randomized the weights we ended up with
very similar explanation and if you look
at this explanation this saliency my
business type of explanation as you
heard they look like the input image
input image it's highlight the bird and
they make sense to me
they have a bird inside but is this the
right explanation we don't know
under this sanitary experiment I think
we have reason to worry whether we're
solving the right problem perhaps this
is solving something else but not what
we are going for
and I cannot overemphasize that just
because when you see you like it doesn't
mean it works it does not mean that it's
showing us
so I talked about how reality that you
can evaluate by making a potato say
where you know the ground truth now I'll
give you an example of this this is some
work that I did with sherry yang at
Google and what we did is pretty simple
so we gathered some scene features
forest kitchen bathroom bedroom and then
we pasted a dog patch
this isn't same dog Corgi every single
picture so the dog doesn't give you any
information about classifying scenes so
while this is part of the image and
being dog perhaps on the bed kind of
make sense to humans the explanation
message should not or attribution method
to be specific she's not highlight the
dog we know that dog wasn't important
and while this is only testing it's very
subset of what attribution method should
or should not detectives of only looking
at false positives it's a good starting
point I think there are many many data
sets you can formulate such that you
know this basic case your method is
doing what you expect to do and if it
doesn't then you should stop right there
and go back to the Rhoyne board says a
dog should not be important we did a
bunch of tests I also tell you but we
haven't defined important how to what
the test sort of a is a putting that
part before the horse yeah we did all
pretty reverse testing to make sure that
dog when it's removed it doesn't affect
the scene we do KL divergence test and
and so on so we proposed a couple of
metrics that are complementary to each
other and we open source model data and
the metrics and we show some the popular
methods on how they do on their this
measure
and remember this is not perfect this is
still a low bar test so semi-natural
data set but it's a starting point this
is something that you can do you can
formulate your own and your own domain
and and test it yes sorry could you
split like how this context of last
interpretive Lily so it just tells you
like if you're on that gets torn off by
the presence of the dog it's oh sorry I
perhaps I should have been a little more
so this is a referring to a particular
type of interpretability method called
attribution methods which is what julius
talked about and the goal of that method
common goal of the method is identify a
pixel or a feature such that when I
remove it then the classification goes
off the rack so the goal is of these
interpretability method is identify
where in the picture were your input
data set that important information lies
and this is just a data set that where
you can do initially
evaluation whether you're your method is
working yes so cool about your method is
predicting the features that would be
predictable predictive for the class but
this is actually testing the inverse
right yes
so which is why it's just testing false
positives
the dog should not be important it's not
the dog should be important or kitchen
should be important we're just testing
that dogs should not be important
hey let's keep going how to fail number
eight I am a computer scientist running
human experiments is outside of the
scope of this paper remember the whole
point of what we are doing is for
consuming consumption if there are no
humans I won't be doing what I'm doing
so if you don't check with your final
customer and you have you might be
creating something that is completely
irrelevant my favorite cartoon I think
it comes from software engineering
context where a customer really wanted
something like this but depending on who
you're talking to you can build
something over build it on their
building and unfortunately 60% of the
papers did not run any human experiments
half of the paper did not even report
any qualitative observations by human
subjects or the end users is that too
broad you apply that argument probably
say don't we know humans that we would
not do any machine learning okay we're
gonna have only qualification questions
only oh let's let's let's talk about
that after I think well I'll have some
so moving on how to fail in interpreting
a method
how to fail number nine the explanation
is always true it is what the model
thinks some interpretability method if
not most of them are a proxy mate
unlike the local explanation that Julius
talked about feeding some linear
function and depending on how you
approximate they will give you different
answers and some will be wrong so it's
really important to communicate this to
users so I thought there is you probably
think of course it's approximate that's
obvious but you know for lay users who
doesn't really know machine learning or
- machinery every day they're in this
machine learning magic hype they like
machine learning and they think it might
be magic and it's really important to
clearly communicate to them that these
explanation or model creations for that
matter - has uncertainty 42 percent of
paper did not explicitly mention that
this is the case 15 percent of papers
took the interpretability result of it
in a interpretability method as a ground
truth and build their argument on top of
it
when you want paper I had explicitly had
I don't know option and what this is is
I can't give you the explanation sorry
and I really I think this is very
important and looking back only one of
my work have has this option all the
other work didn't have this option
an interesting theory question is
whether we can quantify the goodness of
fit over one interpretability method
well I mean well it's on a proxy so can
we figure out and have some good
definition of how well this
approximation is and not so maybe
mathematical setting but something that
more correlates with how humans would
perceive that information and I think
this can go hand-in-hand with the
coverage question that I talked about
perhaps you can have a good
approximation but poor coverage but
maybe you can have a good coverage about
poor approximation maybe there's some
trade-off
how to fail number 10 humans are wise
and logical I have a bad news for you
you're not
and one of there's lots of studies and I
really like a lot of them but I want to
play this game here and this might be
unusually theoretically minded audience
to play this game but I'm gonna give it
a try
so and if you know what this is what I'm
about to do that just don't answer it
okay so I'm gonna give you three numbers
and there's a rule that complies to
these three numbers you can ask me in in
return as three numbers you can give me
three numbers and I'll tell you whether
that number complies with this rule or
not does it mean us no okay so I'll give
you three numbers I give you two four
six there's a rule that this numbers
comply right and you're gonna guess what
the rule is what their thoughts yes yes
but let's let's let's let's go you're
gonna ask me questions to narrow down
what their rule is so two first six give
me numbers that that you think that
comply this rule
Nisha
yes one five three
No
three six nine
yes all right so this this experiment
that we had a too many theoretically
minded people so typically they're
normal people what they ask is when I
give you a four five six two two four
six it's such a even a beautiful even
number right so what they often give is
in return only the even number in
increasing order 4 6 10 12 16 18 and so
on and what this study shows and this
has been proven in large audience is
that humans are inclined to confirm
their hypothesis much more than they
want to falsify their hypothesis we had
two smart audience who figured out give
me the counter example in this
confirmation bias although don't think
that you're not not vulnerable to this
bias I think you are it's something that
I see over and over again in my studies
here these they're the subjects are
doing a task where they just don't know
how to complete a task so random random
guesses 50% and subjects were doing 52%
well this is basically random guess and
they're looking at the same exact set of
pictures one said is right the other
half said B's right and when they reach
that conclusion based on this exact same
picture
they were super confident forty percent
of them were as confident as they will
ever be
looking at st. pictures day reaches
completely different conclusions and
they were the reason of this is that
they were looking for when they looking
at these pictures they're looking for
reasons why they were right the evidence
that confirms their hypothesis rather
than falsified
so how to fail finally and I'll have a
plenty of time for discussions I fail 11
I'm just a researcher who provide
technical tools the real word usage is
something I cannot control and here's a
cute picture of a cat to alleviate the
depressing story that I'm about to share
with you so going day by day writing
papers writing grants teaching classes
it might be a lot to think about
the final consequences of the tools that
you're creating in fact or am I
responsible for what my tool is going to
do in the world a lot of researches
scientists and engineers had dis ask
questions same questions to themselves
in the history famously
the inventor of ak-47 it's an automatic
rifle spend his rest of his life in deep
pain that he might be responsible for
lives that were claimed by his invention
scientists were involved in developing
atomic bomb expressed their regrets
after seeing the devastation in
Hiroshima
the tool interpretability one of the
goal is to help experts making better
decisions in high stake domains and what
that means is these tools might be used
in the front line with domain experts
and I don't think it's too much to say
that the goal the function of these two
is less significant than that of doctors
while nothing can guarantee us from
failing to foresee all the ways our
tools can be used
let's give it a really good thought on
how we might fail envision how you might
fail in ten years twenty years from now
and let's try to avoid that failure as
best as we humanly have so regarding
this question of making something
quantifiable out of an interpretability
type of you know metric suppose you
managed to somehow to do that then I can
see a the two situations happen so you
either incorporate that into your
training objective and then you can turn
into this meta into probability question
in what the interpretive matrix for that
so either you keep doing this forever at
some point you saturate in you're happy
right or maybe interpretability is
inherently some kind of an undecidable
problem which one would it be is your
question that's interesting question I
want to draw maybe analogy to maybe
classification right so we have class
peak we've been building started with
the simple loss function and now we're
doing like meta learning we're doing
Auto ml we're going like meta a meta but
it seems to be helpful but it's also is
raising a lot of questions right I
wouldn't be surprised if what you the
scenario that you're plotting about
interpretability or interpretability it
definitely happens but I I actually
personally think it's the latter I think
it wouldn't be something that
you know your science I love the field
but but it's a really difficult question
like we really struggle to understand
how we reason how humans work I think we
have very little understanding of that
and what that means is that defining
what makes sense or help you the most
in certain tasks it's just going to be
very hard to define
yes I think that it's too much of an
umbrella topic I mean that different
applications different uses maybe for
each of them we should come up with the
difference more concrete definition oh I
think that's a good point because I
think in a way categorizing failure
modes different failure modes this model
fails in that way just model fails in
the other way that's kind of helping you
to use the tool safely too so that you
know when you like maybe robustness also
internally what how would you define
interpretation like right now in ten
minutes I think what I would go for is
and there is a reason why Oh Julia Cisco
Julia so was talking about different
definitions of interoperability because
just like what you said it depends on
the task and the user and I don't think
it's a mathematically definable I can
give you some fuzzy words with that has
give you fuzzy feelings they're kind of
abstract and high-level but I don't know
how useful that would be then same thing
goes for like definitional terminology
in my view it's like
interpretability and expletive they're
different should we define maybe but as
long as you define it well in your paper
what you mean by excellent bility and
Inter probably I'm not too picky about
perhaps it introduces some chaos in the
field but I'm not too picky about that
in a way this would be nice but I don't
think
okay